Yeah. So, make an actual point now. Don't just reiterate what
I'm saying, but go, "Oh, no. I didn't just say support streamers.
I said that the post says we support them and they support us."
Unless what he does actually results in exit
position. You said earlier literally said that before. Literally
said it cannot be. I'm sorry. Literally said that before. Literally
said that several times. Literally, nobody believes you. Yes.
You have two parties saying we are familiar. Listen. Listen to
me. Listen to me. Man, stop talking. I was asking for the one
word answer. The yes or the no. You're afraid of what I'm going
to say. That's why you're talking over me. I don't know. You
just won't let me flatly answer this question. You're not saying
I'm asking you for the yes or the no and you just don't give
it. What do you say? Hold on. Hold on. The way we solve this.
So, go ahead and go back to telling me that I said it can't be
both. No, I said I'm not going to reward you.
Also, I've been reading this like the whole time. So, I'm in
the Collins channel Supreme. I think you should be able to join
this. Yeah, you definitely
I could drag you. You missed. I could drag you.
There we go. Okay. Hello. Hello. Hello. Okay, let's start from
here. Why does copyright exist? Uh because when you create some
unique thing, other people shouldn't just be able to use it or
uh profit from it, right? What is fair use? uh using that copyright
for a public interest or in a way that basically doesn't create
a market replacement like doesn't create a market replacement.
It's we have the four pillars of fair use that uses it in a fair
way. You want me to listen fair way that means you want me it's
you you want to go through the four pillars of fair use? We can
but at first I just want to agree to like a general a broad understanding
of what fair use is, why it exists and how it ties into copyright.
Okay. Would you say that before we so we don't have to even go
down that route? Do you think Ethan No, but we should and I insist
that we do. I insist. I insist that we start reacting to content.
No, no. I'm sorry. We really do need to understand why fair use
exists and how it ties into copyright. Uh, okay. Go ahead. Oh,
see this. [__] I'm asking for your understanding.
Hi. What's up? Hello. Okay.
Very tiny for me to for me to end. I depend. I don't know. No,
you can keep going. Yeah, I don't care. It's not your money,
Jerry. But
I'll take that as a yes. It is not. It's my money. Yeah, it's
fine. Honestly, I think probably
for a while. So, why do you have fair use? Because people could
just copyright like harmful information or information they could
be doing propaganda and broadly we have like a you have like
a first amendment and people should be able to criticize uh other
people's content, other pe the things other people say, even
if that's through some copyrighted work. I think that's probably
a good chunk of it. I had some other reason that I think it exists
before. I think that's I think that's fine. That's a fine place
to start. And I think also because it's because the law wants
to recognize that in the process of advancing these convers conversations
or if we are going to say that like um the creation of media
that is meant to highlight a point or illustrate a point. Sometimes
other people have made this point as well and you may want to
reference it and there should be a way to do this that uses a
small portion that has some limitations basically that create
uh like some reasonable protections for both the person creating
the content, the new piece of content and the person who created
the original piece of content that you're referencing that you're
not using so much of it that the new content acts as a market
substitute, right, for the old piece of content that the the
person who made the old piece of content can still profit from
their work and the person who makes a new piece of content can
profit from their work because it's like uh a valid thing. You
think that's automatically impossible if somebody has the entire
work there? Yeah, virtually in I think in almost 100% of cases,
yes. If if it is if the entire thing is being played in sequence
um and in its entirety, I think it's virtually impossible to
clear fair use. Yeah. Okay. Do you disagree with that or do you
think this is not true? Yeah, I disagree with that. Okay. Why?
I sorry I disagree with that probably mostly out of self-interest.
Like I I think it's possible it goes either way, but I I would
just disagree with that because that's basically what like a
ton of online content is. Okay. Well, if you're asking if the
question is whether it's fair use or not, it's not about what
what you want. And it's also not about whether or not
I don't believe it is clear. You don't believe it is clear? I
don't believe Okay. So why isn't it that movie reviewers would
just release a copy of the movie like with Why didn't movie reviewers
just talk over a movie while it was playing? Why didn't we want
consume movies like that way? movie reviews. Uh movie, there's
things about movies that obviously make it so that that would
violate the fair use reason like reasonable fair use. What's
different about movies than a YouTube video? Pay-per-view. What
is not necessarily? Uh do movie reviewers review like 10-year-old
movies very often? No. What does that matter? I'm I'm not saying
uh you is stuff that's in a theater. Like obviously movie reviewers
traditionally have been people who are about to review movies
who go into theater and are drumming up business for those movies.
If they reviewed the entire movie in it in its entirety, they
there's a really good argument because it's free that there would
be a market replacement there. What I'm asking is why is the
copyright protected status of a movie different from the copyright
protected status of a YouTube video? I believe so within fair
use that is one of the things right creating a market replacement.
It's not inherently different. It has different attributes to
it. What I'm asking is why would the copyright protection of
a movie be different from the cop the protection in copyright
that a YouTube video a copyrighted YouTube video receives like
why is the level why would the level of protection be different
between these two things it's because it has to do with how uh
like how you're has to do with how fair use applies and that
is on a case- by case basis sorry the copyright work is not inherently
different or sorry the copyright protection is not inherently
different it is not but obviously Obviously, if there's an effect
uh if there if we have a market effect as one of the pillars
of fair use, then how you apply fair use to things will have
to do with how they're like commercially sold or how the original
artist benefits from the commercially. I feel like arguing whether
or not this falls under fair use is kind of I I do kind of agree
with Supreme that I think you can probably pretty safely assume
that 99% of React content probably doesn't come under fair use
and would qualify as copyright infringement. Yes. and would qualify
as copyright infringement. Um, so I don't really think it's particular
use to argue on this topic about whether it falls under fair
use, especially we have a disagreement here though. Well, yeah,
but like I I mean JTO is saying that it's unclear and yeah, it's
unclear there isn't like exact precedent to to say we can we
can reasonably assume that this would have similar rules that
you wouldn't just be able to reproduce the entire work. It's
only unclear
uh in the specific technicality of this domain of the internet
in like YouTube content for some because there's not because
important here which was the point. Yeah. I believe Ethan made
this with the explicit idea that people would critique it and
and that it would be a piece that is meant to be reviewed by
other people but critiquing it including on their streams especially
on their streams. In fact, he invited multiple people to watch
it on their streams. He's allowed to do that. He owns the content.
He can invite people to do it. you can permit individuals to
do it. That doesn't mean it's suddenly legal for anyone to do
it. Okay. Okay. That's the basic gist of it is that I understand
YouTube copyrighted content on YouTube to be no different from
a Hollywood feature film. And uh what you do with it, there's
a reason that we never saw any content uh that was an entire
Hollywood feature film played in sequence in its entirety. You
can do a critique of a YouTube video by the same way that actually
Ethan has done all of his critique videos, his entire all of
his content nukes. Like you said, oh, he's gone over these clips
from these other people. Yes, he's inserted clips as they were
relevant as a as a way to illustrate points that he was making
as little as possible is is is like the the rule of thumb when
it comes to using copyrighted content in fair use is to use only
what you need to to illustrate your point. The only arguments
I can see is that there's some argument about the context of
like uh streaming or something that where because you maybe you
could argue the markets are different. It's actually not a marketplacement
because it's going to a different market. Streaming is like a
separate market and people are there for the the chat and the
streamer that that is there and probably wouldn't watch a video
on their own. I think that that could be an argument, but I don't
I don't see that inherently there would be any real reason to
think it would be different um than movies. I I don't really
see that.
I don't think it's different than movies. I think like the copyright
protection is the same. There are different intents you can have
with a piece of art that I would say probably allow you to apply
fair use in some cases. And I think that with the with this work,
I do believe he intended multiple people. He was making like
a a piece of political work like he was making a political statement
that he wanted people to critique and review. But you do not
have to. that does not require a person to rebroadcast all of
the content in sequence in its entirety which is why he has not
done this thing which is why people on YouTube before the he
has done this he has done this yeah absolutely he's done constant
reaction content over the last like year or two okay fair enough
well I can say Ethan was wrong if that's the case or if other
people didn't tell him that he could well no fun it's not it's
not wrong and also Ethan see this is what I'm trying to say is
I think the fair use thing is kind of gay to argue over because
it's not disgreeing Ethan is totally maliciously using copyrights
to take out uh vindict uh uh vendettas. That's obviously true
of people. That could be part of it, but that to me is not that
relevant. Well, no, that is irrelevant to me because that that
is an abuse. You're not protecting your copyright. Copyright
is to protect your copyright, to protect your IP. If you're suing
someone for copyright, it should be because you're protecting
yourself from losses. Ethan's intention is not to protect himself
from losses. Ethan's intention is to chill criticism of him,
to go after the people that have been going after him and to
stop people coming after him. That is the intention and that
is abs that is abusing copyright. I don't think that's true.
I don't think that's true. I think this is consistent for Ethan.
I think he has been arguing that people shouldn't be reacting
like full length for years. Uh and it actually doesn't even matter
if he just recently started doing it. um this is like this the
importance that this could have whether or not you can say just
because you can fit it within like some arguments that he's made
before that does not mean that is not being the same you don't
tell you're not engaging with what I'm saying you're just picking
up on yeah exactly true also you're you're not saying anything
in response to what I'm saying you're just like picking up on
one word so what I'm saying is you just just because it's consistent
with something you've heard from Ethan before does not mean it
is being it is not being used agree with you. I said, "Yeah,
that that's probably part of why he's doing it as well." But
to me, that's not relevant. Probably part No, that's the point.
No, I think this is something he cares about. He's demonstrated
he's care why why snark in the lawsuit. Why snark in the lawsuit?
Because they they uh contributed to this thing happening.
They he's caring about this. You're saying he's going after Snark
because all these people have one thing. He thinks because he
thinks snark posting about those streams caused him significant
loss in revenue and he need he wants to recoup that. He wants
to protect that revenue that he would he lost on his IP. That's
what you're arguing. No, I don't think No, I don't I don't think
that he believes that these individuals in this individual circumstance
caused him many like substantial losses personally. Okay. Phil's
holes in chat is saying they coordinated. Where's the evidence
of them coordinating? There's no evidence of it. Ethan, no. You
don't understand. No, no, no. Hold on. Hold on. Did you not know
that Denims had H3 Snark on her screen after her stream?
There is more. Hold on. He asked me a question. Okay, we'll see.
We'll see. Before we go with quips, I'll just answer this flatly
if that's what you'd prefer. Um because the post itself uh quite
literally says these people have always supported us and we always
support them. Here's where you can go if you if you want to watch
the content without supporting the creator. Here are some places
you can do it. Not these are people. Someone on Reddit says that
they really like me and I've always really liked them. Does that
mean I'm coordinating with them? No, not necessar No, it doesn't
necessar It's not a smoking gun. But if you have Listen, here's
my analogy that I cooked up while watching this this most recent
stream. Okay. Uh since I think that all this react content is
illegal. We're going to say it's like dealing uh heroin or something,
right? Like everybody who watches streams, who's used to like
uh doing react content of full videos start to finish in its
entirety in sequence. We just all use heroin. And so we look
at heroin dealers as just people that are just like normal, totally
normal, cool people that we just, you know what I mean? This
is like a normal thing for our community to do. And we've got
somebody saying, "Hey, Denim's the heroin dealer deals heroin.
If you like heroin, go here at this time where Denim will be
dealing heroin." She's always scratched our backs. We always
scratch her backs and then you go there. I'm answering your question.
You as you asked me a question I really want to answer. You're
going on an extended analogy and I've already got an issue with
it and I'm going explain to you why it's not analogous for sure.
So the reason why that doesn't work is because it assumes that
there is some uh inherent harm to the person consuming the thing.
The reason why heroin is illegal is because the red literally
says for people who want to watch it but don't want to support
the creator. Like you want to make sure
how does it harm the consumer. It doesn't it's not harming the
consumer. So heroin is illegal because it harms the consumer
and people can't make rational decisions about whether to consume
or not. You realize poking holes, right? You say I have no explain
I'm explaining something to you very clearly. Okay. So that's
why that's illegal. When it comes to IP law, the way information
travels has changed drastically in the last just even 5 years,
10 years, 20 years, definitely 30 years, 100%. A lot of those
laws were written before then. When's DMCA? I think it's 2,000
or something. So the idea that these are these are equivalent
or or like compar analogous in any way that heroin which is harmful
to the user and the user cannot make rational decisions about
whether to consume it versus a broad societal change in how we
share information. Yeah, I I think the laws on that you're appealing
to the abstract to say these things are not like this is not
a relevant analogy, but it still is because you ask me where
is the connection where's the evidence of a connection uh between
these people coordinating to do the illegal thing and I'm telling
you that someone says, "Hey, we want to help people who are doing
the illegal thing to do the illegal thing because they've always
scratched our backs and we've always scratched theirs. Here's
where you can find them doing the illegal thing." And then you
go there to where the person is doing the illegal thing and Ethan
is alleging that this person basically has this play bill. You
know what I mean? like posted in their background um you know
of of the person saying like this is where you can find this
person doing the illegal thing. That's the evidence for it. It's
not a smoking gun, but that's evidence. So, okay. So, okay. So,
all you're saying is that because they said they like the streamers
and the streamers like they will support the streamers and the
streamers support them. That's enough to because they said, "Hey,
this copyrighted content will benefit it will benefit the creator
if you watch it on their platform and we want to make sure investigate
the coordination." Well, the coordination is they've always scratched
our backs and we always scratch their backs. Okay. So, you are
saying that alone is coordination. So, why are you saying smoking
gun? Not that alone. Okay. So, what else? You're saying it's
not a smoking gun. You ask me for evidence that they coordinate
coordinated. Yes. So, you're saying to me evidence doesn't have
to be conclusive. Kim, so yes. So, are you saying to me, well,
I just asked you again. Are you saying to me that you think the
Reddit saying they supported us, we'll support them is enough
to look into the idea of coordination? It's two parties demonstrating
familiarity with each other and one of those parties. So, is
that a yes? Are you answering the question or Sorry, what's the
what's the direct question? Okay. For the like sixth time, is
that to you enough to investigate the idea of coordination between
the two parties? Yeah, I think so. I think it's reasonable. Demanding
information from a subpoena. Didn't Didn't I answer this like
four times? No, I don't think it's a smoking gun, but yes, I
think it's evidence. You have two parties saying we are familiar
with each other. allow we're talking about allowing Ethan to
legally compel other parties to hand over like doc's information,
private correspondence. Yes, you have two parties saying we are
familiar. Listen, listen to me. Listen to me. Stop talking for
the one word answer, the yes or the no. You're afraid of what
I'm going to say. That's why you're talking over me. I don't
know. You just won't let me flat the answer. You're not saying
I'm asking you for the yes or the no and you just don't give
it. What are you talking about? Yeah. Hold on. The way we solve
this, the way we solve this is we just go let Subream say yes
and then qualify to some extent. Okay, good. Oh yes, qualify.
Do you acknowledge that you asked me? Do you think this is enough
to investigate like a collusion between the two? And I said
Uh yeah, and I asked you about the subpoena and then you started
just Why did you say that? I couldn't answer that
I just said you started rambling before answering it. I was asking
about compelling, making sure you understood. I was asking about
compelling people to hand over information. Listen, I got Listen,
to be clear, I don't know the legal standard for when uh evidence
is I'm asking morally like, do you think that's okay? Do you
think that that's that's something you want to happen? Yes. Yeah.
Okay. You're not worried about the chilling effect that could
have on speech where anonymous users are being outed for simply
saying they support streamers? No. Because listen, this isn't
a a general statement we support streamers. It isn't a statement
saying we like this and they support those streamers. Oh my god.
Can I make a point before you interrupt me?
Just fill in the quote. Fill in the quote. When I say support,
fill in the full quote in your head. Okay. I I literally was
doing that just so you're aware. That is exactly what I was doing
out loud. You were doing it out loud. I said in your head. Huh?
You want me to You want me to answer your question in my head?
No, I want you to fill out the rest of the statement in your
head when I go. I want you to figure out what I mean by that.
Super. Okay. Here we go. I'm going to fill out the rest of the
statement in my head. Okay, here I go. Okay, I did it. How does
that help the conversation? So, yeah. So, make an actual point
now. Don't just reiterate what I'm saying, but go, "Oh, no. I
didn't just say support streamers. I said that the post says
we support them and they support us and uh go watch them." Have
an actual conversation. Holy. Just like actually pretend that
you don't know each other from before. I'm doing my best. I'm
doing my best. Thank you. I keep
ramble every time. You say I'm filibustering, but you just keep
interrupting as soon as I get one point into an argument that
has maybe three or four points in totality.
Okay. When I say support and you immediately pick up on that
and go, it's not just support, it's and then you're about to
explain the Reddit post again. I am saying just I'm saying just
fill in the details of that Reddit post. It's obvious I'm referring
to that Reddit post to you, Supreme. So, just fill that in in
your head. I'm using supports the streamers as a standin for
the Red because what you asked me was this have a chilling effect
on people saying they support other people. It's not. No, I'm
not just saying it about the quote support
making posts supportive of streamers directing people towards
their content. No, I don't think it'll have a chilling effect
on that if people understand what the specific thing that was
done like is that's being alleged is against the law. Well, it's
not just about what's alleged. It's about what what the saying,
wait a minute, if you go after this person for pir for selling
pirated movies, won't that put a chilling effect on people telling
each other about movies they like? No. Um, no. But if you say
like for instance, we could imagine a situation where um maybe
there's like a fan film or something and people are directing
people towards a fan film in in uh opposition to a main release
by the actual company and then in that case may maybe you could
start thinking about that. That would be being an argument. Yeah.
Um I'm sorry I just can you rephrase that? So, let's imagine
there's like a fan film being made around the same time as like
a main release by a big studio and people direct people towards
the fan film and say, "Oh, don't see that main one. Don't see
that. Go see the fan film instead. Go watch this fan film online.
It's free or whatever." Now, you can start seeing like a different
uh argument, right? That that in that case, there could be a
chilling effect on people recommending that that type of content
that you go see a fan film. Yeah. Yeah. What you're not getting
you go see a different piece of content than the one instead
of rebroadcasting something that's copyright protected. We're
not talking about the people rebroadcasting right now. And they're
not just rebroadcasting it is technically it's like a a new work.
It might not be transformative, but it is a an Well, they are
rebroadcasting it. They're just also adding to it. Well, yeah,
it's an iterative work, but I mean that's that's I think fan
films would be like iterative works in a way because they're
iterating on someone else's IP. So, yeah, that's true. But that's
kind of my point, right? It's like you don't want the chill I
don't want the chilling effect on the discussion of this content
throughout the lawsuit. It's not just arguments about but you
know I think that does from if the decisions that Ethan wants
made are made based on the arguments Ethan's making that lawsuit
there will be a chilling effect because a lot of the arguments
he's making that lawsuit things like Denims is too uninformed
to give substantive commentary. Well, if the person watching
it being informed matters, well then that opens up a whole can
of worms for for free speech. Uh, no it doesn't because this
is how content of this nature has operated forever until the
internet. Okay. You understand that when a case goes through
the courts, new precedent can be set that could affect future
cases. Yeah. But the thing is I think the old standard is better
and applies in that the current paradigm has just been slow to
adopt the new standard because nobody has just brought it to
a court before. Okay. So you think it's actually based to just
get rid of all react content and you just you're okay with that
in in its entirety? Yes. Absolutely. I think it's absolutely
this is not inconsistent for me. I don't know if you know this
about me, but I have been on this soap box for like years and
it like even when I was streaming uh basically when the Jaxi
thing came around, I watched I literally I reacted to Jax's video
like start to finish. And then I was on a panel with like him
and uh and Kraut the history guy or I'm sorry they I they them
I don't know if Jaxi how they identify. Um but like and I think
a few other people and I basically was made aware that there's
there are like a lot of big YouTubers that pine for like the
copyright protections of old. uh and they're really sick. Just
like Lemino, I think is one of the people that kind of came out
and said it, but because of the reaction that I think Let me
know and some other people got like a lot of YouTubers kind of
had to subdue themselves under the surface. And I don't know
why I'm telling you this because I literally can't prove it.
Like it's just word of mouth. Um this is something I was told.
But um you know, and I started to feel pretty passionate about
this and like I started to develop an understanding of fair use
and copyright and like the best way for me to engage with that.
And for years, I would not basically from this time until I stopped
streaming, I would not do react content unless I had the express
permission of uh either the creator or whoever held the rights
of like a given series or channel or something like that. I just
don't know why you would like why any of those YouTubers would
give a single about React content at this point when their entire
jobs would be taken by AI within like a year. Well, let me know
is the first one to go. So, I don't know why they would even
give about react content at this point. There's a whole different
copyright issue they've got to deal with. I mean that's you're
no longer engaging in the topic we No, but I mean if your concern
is about the state of the market then there's bigger threats
and I think this is like just attacking like you know a and the
results of that market shift are yet to be seen and maybe the
AI threat will end up being like so much more threatening to
so many more people um that maybe that spurs like some sort of
legal protections or actions uh in a quicker amount of time or
maybe it doesn't. I don't know the I just I just don't have a
lot of interest in like engaging with the absolutist like no
react content position. I thought you had a more like normal
position on this, but I don't care. Well, it that actually kind
of Yeah, I think that people were sort of lulled into thinking
that React content was like normal and that there was nothing
wrong with it. But I mean like thinking about it for one second
it seems pretty obvious that well actually it is a little harder
than thinking about it for one second because I mean like my
conception of of why this is a problem is that yes there are
big fish um you know there are XQC's and there asmin golds that
are basically creating an environment and um and I you know I
I don't know if you guys remember I called in and talked to like
XQC and Turkey Tom and and Destiny about this where I said like
this is creating an environment where we are no longer rewarding
people uh for like providing new creative original works and
this is like shifting the market towards you know basically just
like regurgitating things and um you know like the constitution
actually protects like this is the the foundation of of copyright
law is in the constitution
um new original works right and uh and I think that's kind of
what we should be vying for one is a system that continues to
protect creators rights to profit from their work and for people
to not steal from them basically which is what copyright is is
you know kind of the foundation for and um yeah and and it like
so we have big fish yes we have bigger offenders we have XQC's
and asmin goals but the pond now is just huge where I think even
every little fish contributes to this environment being so uh
pervasive that you know like so much of YouTube is just deriv
is just laziness right I mean that's kind of the the trend for
any sort of like uh any sort of labor right any sort of production
is that you try to produce uh you know with as little effort
as possible for as much profit as possible, but I think we've
reached like a critical mass. That just sounds like the same
boomer talk that you'd hear in like any generation deserve to
be to profit from their work. Don't care. I do not think that
is information world ways. It's just different. So, we've got
we've got like no license here, right? There isn't like a licensing
agreement, but essentially what this is is like Ethan's work
is open to everybody unless he wants to sue you. That seems like
a problem to me. That seems like a precedent that you should
be able to set. He literally says like, didn't he say it in that
video? Like, I don't care if you, you know what I mean, you criticize
me or whatever, like just don't play my entire video from start
to finish. No, he said references from start to finish without
commentary. He said with good commentary, I have no problem.
Yeah, but again, that's also his commentary. That's also his
individual beef. I just don't buy the whole idea of you, but
he's suing based on them violating his individual beef. And and
Denims took that and I know this isn't the only measure, but
she took measure. She only took she took that 1 hour 50-minute
video and she turned it into four hours of content, right? Like
I think she absolutely made commentary on it. Okay. But but I
personally don't think that's relevant. Um because you know again
like it's a complete substitution like it was advertised. I would
say Sure. Sure. I would just say that it goes to it being like
he's not he hasn't DMCA Destiny. He hasn't DMCA Asmin Gold. He
hasn't he hasn't gone after any of these people. He's going after
Denims who has transformed it but transformed it with negative
commentary who he doesn't No no no no with stated with the express
purpose of like not giving yeah sure with maliciousness but I
don't know how much that like yeah I don't know whether stated
malice actually matters that much in terms of assessing whether
it's a market replacement or not because it makes it an easier
lawsuit and if this is a thing that he broadly cares about it's
it's just low hanging fruit. It's just an easier slam dunk case
to generate precedence.
It's not because the maliciousness actually doesn't change anything
on the fair use guidelines. He would have the same if you think
it's a slam dunk here. The maliciousness does not actually change
anything as far as the fair use argument and and suing for copyright
goes. The only difference is it allows him to pursue statutory
damages against these people. He can these people without actual
damages done to him. And that is what he is trying to do. Yes.
But that's that's like a new brick, right, in the road that now
YouTube and Twitch have to look at and generate new policy for
because it's a new liability on the books that they've never
seen before. Maybe I'll be back in a bit cuz I I'm only really
interested to argue with people who aren't totally against React
content. I I just I don't care about that position. You can I
think react you can do react content just not all the way through
start to finish. It should be as little as possible. People react
to clips all the time. Anyone wants to get like start to finish
react content? Yeah, that's especially cuz in this context when
Ethan constantly cries about being clipped. Um yeah, I just don't
care about arguing this position. Listen, I think Ethan's petty.
Okay, I think Ethan is doing this to hurt people who hurt him.
But sometimes we use the justice system uh to find justice and
sometimes part of justice is punishing people who broke the law
to hurt you. And they may be people that you hate and that hate
you. And that's what happened. Well, I'm going to be back in
like half an hour cuz I'm just crash stream. Okay, go. See you.
See you. It's losing his game. Oh, is he is he on kick right
now? Yeah, I think he elo
Oh, that's almost certainly what's happening, isn't it? Yeah,
for sure. Yeah, but I think um I think we're pretty much on the
same page that he's doing this to to fight off people who have
criticized him. Supreme, thank you for thinking I'm cleaning.
Yo, I this has been coming. Thanks, Supreme. Yeah, I just want
to congratulate you. You know what? I got to be honest. I'm I'm
just really happy that like things calmed down and we had a conversation
at the end that was really obnoxious at the beginning. Uh-huh.
Yeah. Um,
can be that way sometimes. I think I think Freeman is a a smart
kid who thinks about things and I'm glad to have that conversation.
It's like not that young. He's like 27 or something. No, he's
going to be a kid forever. Have you seen him? I don't know about
thinking through the whole helps like self-hating. I don't know
how far that's going to get him. Going to have to figure out
how to love himself soon. That's going to get old fast. I think
it's endearing. It's a core part of his character. You know,
that whole self-hating quirk. I don't even know that that's true.
People have said it about him. Ruben, what do you think about
that? What I just said about like sometimes the justice system
means sometimes justice means like holding people accountable
for breaking the law to hurt you even if you hate them and they
hate you. And often times that's true, right? In in the justice
system. Often times the people you are bringing to court hate
you and you hate them. Sure. But then you don't make a video
saying I this is the same moral moral drama I've been beating
all of this time because that's not what he's doing. He's not
trying to get a moral he's really not trying to do that at all.
He is just trying to hurt the people who hurt him. So I all I
want is for him if he's just trying to bully them back, if he's
just trying to hurt them, then that's fine. But say that. Just
that's what you're doing. Take off this Superman cape like you
are protecting everybody. Please stop pretending there's like
a moral argument here. It can't be both. No, if it was both,
he would go after somebody doing actual harm. No, it can be both.
The point is the other people doing actual harm here. He has
a unique collection of people stating malice.
It makes it an easier case. It makes it a cheaper case. It makes
it a less lengthy case. uh because they don't have the money
to like fight him back on this, right? That's part of it. Sure.
But also because of the details and the fact that they incriminated
themselves, but that's why I said you don't give him the cape
this time. He doesn't get the cape this time. If he's taking
the easy route, the only reason to take the easy route is to
eventually get to the point where you are suing the big dogs.
That you the whole reason you're wearing the cape is because
you want to go out might have the same impact as suing the big
dogs until No, until there's actually a lawsuit against the big
dogs. until it actually stops their behavior. What is the reason
to celebrate him? There is Well, not necessarily. This again,
this lawsuit may generate the precedence that would have the
same impact
um that that going after the big dogs would have if YouTube and
Twitch look at this and they now have to generate new policy
going forward about like React content and how how is it any
different even after what it also may have an impact of is nothing
except for hurting these three streamers. That's yeah, that's
true as well. That may be the case, but I don't I'm not sure.
I don't think so. I think the likelihood is pretty high that
I mean this is going to get noticed and it's a landmark case,
right? Like this I don't think this has ever been done before.
And I think her stated purpose that they actually put in here
was to criticize and I think criticism especially criticism of
political topics andor like political groups is something that
is absolutely open to like like it's in the public interest to
do so. I think she has like a bunch of arguments on her side.
I don't think she'll win, but I think she I don't think malice
was her primary reason for doing this. I think even if she didn't
hate Ethan, she would have been going in on the same content.
It was the same thing everybody else in the internet was doing
that day at that time. I don't think Malice really weighed into
her decision to cover it exactly when she did. I mean, didn't
she say herself at the very end if you enjoyed making sure this
guy didn't get the money for his video? I think have you like
forgotten that? Uh, she said the next day. So there's a lot of
people who wanted to watch somebody disagree with it. No, I'm
sorry. Are we looking Are we talking about the exact same thing
that's on your screen
right now? We're talking about the same page of the lawsuit.
Yes. Hold on. It says uh making petty jokes is really hard for
me to feel like, yeah,
this person. It says people who uh people there were a lot of
people that came to Wasn't this person already suing her? Oh,
maybe not at this time. No, no, not at this time. CPS was after
this, right? To be clear, it doesn't say uh people came here
to watch an analysis. It says people came here to watch it because
they wanted to see what somebody who would disagree with it would
say. But saying things that you disagree with in a video that
you're watching in its entirety does not like this. It's still
legal, but whatever. I mean, that's I guess that's a separate
argument, but the point is you're saying, "Oh, she said this
the next day." What does it matter? Like, she demonstrated that
she did it, that she was happy that she We We can like We can
quibble about this all we want. Uh from a moral basis for me,
Ethan had been in a back and forth with these people for over
a year, these exact people. He wanted them all to comment. He
said they were too much to comment and he wanted the political
argument back and forth. He want he was like, "Here are my criticisms.
You are too scared to look at them." And then when somebody did
look at them, he is now suing them. He looks like the biggest
onet earth. Not like the whiniest [__] on planet
earth and that's never going to change. Anybody can look at this
in an unbiased way. I I understand your opinion, but you keep
forgetting that it's not that they watched it. Okay, you can
say this person will never watch this, but that does not necessitate
that watching it means rebroadcasting copyrighted content from
start to finish in sequence. Uh but it did for like a ton of
other people on the internet. What does that mean? Shell game
over to maliciousness. Now we should probably
because a thousand like 10,000 other people did that exact same
thing and he's not suing any of them. So what is the difference
is the difference this is the one person who says she commented
on other people not wanting to watch it and that she was somebody
he hated right and that they had been engaging in back and forth
commentary for over a year and at the end of watching it she
said the reason I did that was to make sure that I reduced his
income for this create video that he created so that you watching
it would not have benefited him. That's not that's not what she
says. She says if you enjoyed making sure this guy didn't get
money. Yeah. You want to defend that? Why can't she comment on
why the audience is there, why her audience is so much bigger?
Huh?
She's not commenting on her motive for watching it, which I believe
is to criticize it. She's commenting on her motive or sorry,
the audience's motive for watching her. That her audience went
from 3,000 people to 45,000 people. So, she's acknowledging that
in effect that's what she was doing and taking joy in it.
You've lost it, man. You've lost the plot. you stuck your foot
in before you actually watched the video, knew what the arguments
were. Is that or her direction if she says it at the end of doing
what she did? Is that giving them instructions to do that or
acknowledging it after the fact? Did she coordinate? Yeah. Did
she coordinate it? So, how would you feel if we found out that
she did have the snark post up in the background and that basically
she knew that people were being directed to it before she started
watching it under the premise of if you want to watch the video
without benefiting Ethan, you can do it here. And she's like,
"Yeah, I am doing that here." So you think that So the hypothetical
is simply with this person she'd been fighting with year who'd
been directing harassment at her possibly justifiably for over
a year. You think she only would have watched this if Snark made
that post? No, that's not making at all. It absolutely is. No,
you're following. This is just This is actually why she's like
one of the people that get sued. This is like the Kelly effect.
So long as she is the person, so long as she's like the defendant,
then just nothing is justified. There's like no there's no other
way to look at this but this Well, you're talking to the wrong
guy cuz I I think it would be justified to go after anybody like
Yeah, I think this is a there's there's like certain there are
certain people uh on this platform where as so long as something
bad happens to them, it's like not a bad thing anymore. I think
I think there's that's true for a lot of people interpreting
this. Yeah. On either side actually. like a lot of the people
saying Ethan is doing a screen and Yeah. Go ahead. Well, no,
I I agree with you and I think that's happening on both sides,
but that's that person is not in the room with us. Well, I think
that some of the arguments against um against denims or some
of the arguments that just like validate like Ethan's move right
now is literally because of that. It's just because it's denims.
Yeah, I think that's true. on top of what Jason Hunter is saying
is he doesn't deserve a cape for this because Hunter right now
elucidate what her crime is and then explain to me how that per
how she's the only person who's uh who's actually doing this
crime. Okay. So, you have to elucidate what her crime is and
you have to tell me exactly what she's done that's unique and
not the same as a ton of other people.
Go ahead.
because I'm I'm tired of people just trying to hop hopscotch
all over the place, right? Oh, well, what she did wasn't unique.
A whole bunch of other people did it, but she did break the law,
so she should face the consequences. But also, like, yeah, he
was harassing her and and and yeah, like obviously it's been
a back and forth the whole year, but I I mean, obviously she
had she only reason she did it was cuz she's malicious. She's
malicious, guys. She's malicious. She would have been reacting
to this no matter what. Here's what I'll say. Ethan is allowed
to cherrypick who he goes after. And when he does so, he does
not get to play the role of I'm the hero for YouTube. I'm taking
down the big guy for the little guys. He doesn't get to do that.
He's just he's taking out his own personal what whatever vendetta.
King Morgot. Say what it is. How? Yes. Yes. I don't know why.
Here's the thing. Loki Coco and King Morgot, you're both going
to be banned from chat unless you go watch those four hours and
prove to me. Okay. Make a very quick clip of those four hours.
Compress it down 100 times like the be movie and show me that
she didn't speak at all cuz you're if you think she turned an
hour and 50minute video into four hours without talking. That's
not even claimed by Ethan in the lawsuit. How about you will
shut the up. Sorry, getting one guy a little bit. I just like
I don't know why you guys discount that there is 0% alignment
with something that you may have already wanted to accomplish.
It seems like this is a thing that he did want to accomplish.
Yeah. It's just acknowledging like, hey, the thing that you originally
wanted to do was go after XQC, but for some reason, you're wearing
the same, you're like riding the same torch as if you're going
after XQC, but really this is the move that you made it to accomplish
that. Exactly. Exactly. So, stop acting like you're doing the
hard heroic thing. That's all we're saying. Well, I think what
he's doing is a good acknowledge you are being petty. You are
doing something for yourself. This is the hate that you've been
receiving. this is like particularly beneficial to you and the
effect that it's had on you is literally nothing anybody else
feels. That can be true. That could be true. But I don't I don't
understand like I don't think you guys would make the same argument
like staring down your nose about somebody who like wants to
see a murderer get life in prison when when they murdered somebody
close to them or something. Yeah, you can do you can do the same
thing. you can like testify in such a way that you hope the judge
throws the book at them and you know like grants the maximum
punishment available for somebody who did something that hurt
you. I don't even know what you're saying right now. How it how
it that's what I'm talking about because you're saying he doesn't
deserve a cape because he's litigating against um he's like bringing
people to court that uh that he really doesn't like that did
something bad to him. And I'm saying this happens. This is what
the justice system is when people hurt other people. sometimes
part of fine, but he just does not want to own up to it. He does
not want people to look at him like he's petty or like he got
his feelings hurt on the internet. He's acting like he's doing
this for everyone else. Just say what it is. The fact that you
try to sell it to everybody like you the hero, like you are sticking
up for the underdogs. That is weird. Has he not been open about
like how much this has affected him and like how betrayed he
feels? Did you watch the video? Sorry. Has he not? No.
all those other details. We know that it's petty. Yeah.
I don't know if it is petty. I think we can agree that like over
the last year you've gone back you've agreed with us with with
us that it's petty. You you've actually said you can you can
fight on something you want. You can get justice via the justice
system and
he doesn't like where it's led him. So now he's going to like
rewind. What I said was it's true that he is trying to hurt like
the people as well. Like that's a part of his motivation. I didn't
say uh you know I may have said I may have said like petty grievance
or something but that's that's the spirit of what I'm saying
is that like yeah I think that can be part of like the impetus
for why we said petty but it's different when you say listen
has he not been doing streams for a year where he's like these
people all turned on me and what did I do to them? Has he not
demonstrated like vulnerability and that he's been hurt over
like the reaction and the way that people have been talking about
him and treating him. You guys are analyzing this the way that
he never said there was nothing wrong with it. Just the fact
that he makes it seem like there's something wrong with it. The
fact that he does not want to just be like, "Hey, they did this
to me and I think that'sed up, so yeah, I'm going to sue them."
He is the one who's making it seem like he is fighting for all
the small YouTubers and it's up that you do this to YouTubers.
Like if if there is nothing wrong with him taking out this vendetta
and like protecting himself using the law, then just do that.
Um Okay. Yeah. But I don't know. I think it can also Why can't
it be both of these things? Why can't it be both these things?
No, it can't. It can't because if there's nothing wrong with
just going and taking someone to court because they've wronged
you. If there's nothing wrong with that, then why can't it just
be that? Why does he have to pretend like he's doing it just
taking down the big offenders of this? It's not both. I'm not
the one creating a rule of exclusion. That's what you're doing.
You're saying because this one thing is true, it can't also be
the other thing. I said that I won't give him the other thing
unless this these things to these three smaller streamers actually
ends up affecting how XQC and Asmin Gold engage with React content
because I don't believe that just filing against Denims and these
other women that doesn't actually result into anything. So yeah,
I'm not going to give him any kudos. I'm not going to put that
until it actually affects change. So he
see explicitly but go ahead. If part of his motivation, okay,
if even if it's 10%, even if it's 5% of his motivation is because
he wants to generate precedence to accomplish this thing that
he has already staked uh a pretty uh you know a pretty uh solid
claim for years now about React content. This is the easiest
way to achieve it. much easier than going after Asmin Gold
that literally no one else unless they have like comical villains
that they're that are like stealing their content. No one else
will be able to set up their case like this. No one else has
somebody who's going to sit there and be like, "Haha, watch me
instead of this YouTuber that we're going to steal this video
from today, chat." But the but the right. So, who the is he helping?
Literally nobody else. But that's a that's not necessarily relevant
because the impact may be the same. average smaller YouTuber
does not have the means to actually prove what he's proving in
court. No. So, who is he? That doesn't matter because if what
he is I I feel like at this point we've already st our positions
and now we're kind of just going in circles. I've I think I've
already explained this before where you know like generating
this precedence may have the same impact where platforms go and
have to rewrite their policies to accommodate for the fact that
there's now a new liability that they have to be concerned about.
Whether it was Asmin Gold that got sued for doing this category
of thing that's like 99% aligned missing this one factor or something
like that or whether it's denims and Froggen or whatever,
but I know I've said that.
I just I think he's he's totally he doesn't care what iota about
the actual problem of React content. It's p it's purely that
these people don't like him and he doesn't like these people.
Oh, it's really inconvenient for you that he's been talking about
this for like years. So, uh, so if he exempted the person who
is probably the worst for this, the person he's criticized forever
just because they didn't do it maliciously for this one video,
would that change your mind? Wait, did he exempt him? Did he
say XQC can just do this forever? I don't even know. He literally
showed XQC and he is not the one I'm suing despite my critic.
He's not a Oh, hold on. You're not watching the presentation
or do you finish what you're saying or I'll hit play after? No,
go ahead. You've got the you got the clip. I get XQC, but he
is not the one I'm suing. Despite my criticism, he's not a malicious
infringer. But the ones I am suing, you'll see, are much, much
worse. Now, ironic, they're not. They're actually They're actually
less bad. Denims is literally less bad. Yeah. In total scale,
yeah, of course. But, um, like No. No. No. In terms of actual
actual materially like reacting and trying to transform the content,
Denims did actual work. XQC did not. XQC did Stop right there.
Have we already watched the part where you're saying that he
exempted XQC? Yes. He said, "I'm not going after XQC
to did not do this maliciously." So, wait,
he's not despite our disagreements, he's not the one I'm suing
because he didn't have he didn't exhibit factor that is the thing
that I'm suing all these people for. Are you in the presentation?
Did you watch the video? Me? Yeah. Just now. Did you watch the
video with us? Yes. It's he said despite our uh disagreement
or despite my criticisms, he said he's not the one I'm suing.
That doesn't mean that he's
not a malicious to do this forever. Not a malicious infringer.
Yes. He wouldn't fit in the lawsuit because that's what the lawsuit
is is like it requires that factor. Does not require that's not
the same as creating. Why does it require Hold on. Why does it
explain to me why it requires that factor? Because the nature
that's the nature of the lawsuit that he's pursuing. What do
you No, the nature there there's no requirement for malice in
terms of uh copyright infringement. But that's what he's pursuing.
He's pursuing a case that includes that. So he's not actually
helping any and XQC wouldn't fit into that. So he's not Yes.
That's what he said over his petty vendetta with these people
who said, "Yeah, you can watch us and and not I don't know why
you guys are missing. I don't know why you guys." So this doesn't
actually help anybody who's gotten their copyright stolen. Isn't
about copyright infringement. It's about his vendetta. It's about
these people trying to [__] me over. So you claimed
he exempted XQC, but he did no such thing. He just said, "I'm
not suing him right now cuz he doesn't fit in." He does not say
right now. Oh, holy. I can't I can't talk anymore. I'm done.
Uh,
significantly shorter reaction. Significantly shorter reaction.
5.1K views on the re-upload of Denim's TTV archive for for Denim's
reaction. Basically 4 hours. XQC
XQC has permission to do this and I will never pursue him legally
for this. He didn't say it. He's not pursuing him legally and
XQC is a far more egregious violator of his just let's just agree
on this. XQC is a far more egregious violator of his copyright.
Yes. Yes. Let's just acknowledge this. Going after XQC would
be a much more expensive and lengthy and difficult No, that's
not I didn't ask that. You need to say you don't want to answer.
I answered your question. You don't want to answer mine. Okay.
Sorry. I didn't know when you said yes. I wasn't sure if you
were saying it to that. You were saying yes. He is far more egregious
copyright infringement. Yes. Okay. Perfect. All right. Then yeah,
he might not. I I don't believe that he doesn't want to go after
XQC because it's an easier lawsuit. I believe he won't go after
SQC because then he has to deal with actually people criticizing
him and being mad at him and Dan Saltman's the person who's probably
encouraging him to do this. He's the person who gave him the
pattern who gave him the the Library of Congress the way to register
it. He would say don't go after XQC.
I think it has nothing to do with morality. It has nothing to
do with like uh actually pursuing a case or anything moral at
all. It has to do with these people.
It's sides. We're all sides now. I'm going after the other side.
You That's what it is. That's all it is. All petty. I agree with
you 100% that Ethan is acting under the influence of Dan Saltman
for for obviously for like the Hassan content nuke and like a
lot of the things after. It's it's obvious that he's kind of
just repeating things Dan is telling him. I have no disagreement
with that. But the problem is you guys are making the positive
claim that there's no way Ethan is at all motivated by the thing
that he the position that he has consistently held and jumped
on a soap box to preach about for
so annoying cuz you just need to be No, you aren't saying he's
not primarily%
give them a position that they don't have because you actually
don't have position. No, did you not say it is 0% the other thing?
It can only be this one thing. It can only be the
you realize that's the that even if she said that that would
be the only thing you're hanging on to when like realistically
it's just the majority that's not his majority reason. Obviously
not because his compass is being weighted way more towards these
people who he dislikes than it is towards XQC the far more egregious
copyright infringer and the person who's causing far more actual
harm. I've quite literally said I will not let him work unless
what he does unless what he does actually results in exit changing
your position. You said earlier it cannot literally said that
before. Literally said it cannot be both. I'm sorry. Literally
said that before. Literally said that several times. Literally
nobody believes you.
Sorry. You said several times that it could be both things. I
said what I was talking about, but you wanted to talk over me
and tell me that that's not what I said cuz you just want to
obiscate me. Whatever the it is that you're doing. You're in
disagreed on it cuz I said he could be motivated by both things.
Could be 5% this thing or 10% this thing. You said, "Nope, it
can only be one." Okay. I think this is like your caller, Jay-
Sock. So, go ahead. Okay. I I'm I've made my argument. I My argument
is like laid out. It's uh it's pretty simple. Yeah. I don't know.
So does mine. You keep agreeing with me that it would be more
difficult and more expensive to go after XQC. I keep agreeing
with you that Yeah. Part of What did Ethan open the stream with?
What did Ethan open his video with? Uh well, let's watch it again.
I I don't remember. Okay. I'm just saying it's what you want
to do. The the problem is you're using as evidence the fact that
it is 0%.
Nope. Nope. The problem is you don't know what the I said. As
in I said I'm not giving him a cape for doing this on behalf
of the smaller streamers or to change the behavior of Asmin Gold
or XQC until it actually changes the behavior of Asmin Gold or
XQC. Right now, he's doing this petty lawsuit. He's doing uh
going after smaller streamers that he feels like he can win against.
And if that leads him to actually suing XQC, then I'll give him
those kudos. You and a bunch of other losers want to just act
like, "Oh, yeah, he's principled. He's on his this." I literally
said that he's he's doing this partially because like somebody
who heard So go ahead and go back to telling me that I said it
can't be both. No, I said I'm not
the one where he's the king. Supreme said that it's way cheaper,
easier, and my argument is going to be that Ethan doesn't care
about that. And my proof of that is going to be the opening to
this video. Oh, he comes out. My name is Ethan Klein and my favorite
hobby is spending hundreds of thousands of dollars on lawyers.
Today I invite Wow. It's almost like he's ready to throw away
a bunch of money and to fight on principal right now, right?
Hey, just because he's got you money, he's going to go after
this. He's going to actually pursue this because it means something
to him. But what means something to him is destroying Caseyron,
Denims, and Froggen. That's what means something to him. He doesn't
give a about other YouTubers. he doesn't give a about copyright.
He's a loser. You know what? Thinks he can get the snark mods
details as well cuz that's the real war he wants to wage is on
people talking negatively about him online. I just want to say
you know what I I you I was wrong. You're right. He is certainly
part of his motivation is hurting these people and I'm sorry
that I did not agree to this like three times. You say
the majority of his motivation just to be clear agree
100 times. the majority 100 times the majority that so we have
a disagreement you think it's a part of it I said it's the majority
that is the disagreement let's just make it very lit
five or 10% the other thing that means that I kind of yeah agree
that it could also be like the overwhelming majority I never
disagree with this one time but you know oh you totally then
why why have we been arguing why didn't you just say oh I agree
with you that it could be the overwhelming majority you never
said that you I literally have said this like many many times
now at this point and just for the record your argument was He
doesn't give a about the copyright stuff. Okay, which implies
he cares 0% about the copyright stuff. I keep telling you cares
very little. He cares sub 15%. I'm glad I moved your position.
15% is between 0 and 15. Yeah, I probably Yeah, I think so. Okay.
Well, it was productive. Thanks, guys. Did you want to talk to
me? I won. Hold on. Not Not if you're just arguing the absolute.
Sorry. Just want I wasn't trying to say I don't give a about
what you think. Supreme. Sorry. I was I was leaving quite abruptly
a moment ago. I would say I don't give what you think. It's just
when I'm talking about this, I'm assuming that the people I'm
talking to don't want me and everyone I know to lose our jobs
and those are people I'm trying to convince. Um I think that
the way you do your job might have to change and be legal. So
it's not I I totally disagree because the standard within political
content and within commentary content and that Ethan has set
out is that you respond to all the arguments and you play you
play the video in full. So if you have an absolutist
not using the full content position, you're not someone I'm interested
in arguing. I actually, you know what? Like I don't blame you
for that's the paradigm you grew up with. You're like 15 or 16.
Like you literally grew up with you.
If you want to argue about this. Yeah. So I And I'm also going
to say if you want to argue about this, I think the toothpaste
totally out of the tube on IP at this point. And the way the
internet works, the way we communicate with each other is by
downloading stuff, reposting, sharing, constantly ripping and
posting around. You guys simply are intelligent people in the
first world. You're not [__] Chinese cyber marketeers
like or the [__] little guy is never going to be
able to protect their copyright. The little guy is never going
to be able to do it without us having some like insanely draconian
like uh rules on every platform. Yeah, we need new mechanisms
to make sure that you can. I agree. Yeah. And we're we're too
late for this. like uh we're 10 years behind on this. I agree
100%.
No, I'm saying it's not 10. I'm saying too late as in
we got to sort this out. It need to be sorted out. Bad news years
ago. I think there No, I don't I don't think there's any time
in a way that only benefits the the top studios basically and
top content creators. Not necessar I mean DMCA was introduced
like for this very reason and I mean we got a pretty swift like
resolution a new like from the first uh what was it called? The
um ad apocalypse or whatever, right? that kind of brought new
mechanisms. Who's to say we can't iterate over it again and say,
you know what, here's this new trend that started gaining popularity
3 or 4 years ago. Why are we saying that that's now a totally
unreasonable turnaround time uh to generate new policies for
this sort of thing? So, it makes it difficult to engage and respond
like any more mechanisms that you add in that are like copyright
strikeesque or whatever are going to make it more difficult for
users to engage and respond with each other's thoughts and beliefs.
Yeah, that is something fundamentally that almost everyone it's
not it's not currently difficult enough. Yeah, I think most people
just completely would disagree with that. The problem is is the
the ease is going to lean towards free speech against against
IP law. I I would No, the problem is that you can have intersections
of these things that we value. Yeah, I agree. Yeah. Yeah. And
they cross over. Exactly. I think I'm pushing a ball here and
I believe at the expense of people I'm saying I think free speech
should be prioritized even if that's at the expense of of people's
ability to retain their intellectual property. No, you just want
to max easy and it's fun and you don't want to have to open an
editor or hire an editor. I haven't What are you talking about?
I pay there you go. You don't want to pay your editor more because
it'll require more time than just like I would I could get my
to do more work for the same money. Trust me, Supreme, it's not
legit. I could I could literally this is not a problem. Ultimately
I probably could and it was a that was an accusation on my part
like but I genuinely think that you are arguing from that like
motivated reasoning. Yeah because because listen I was a streamer.
I know react content is easy but I'm not saying it just from
motivated reasoning. This is a position that I've held since
before I started streaming that I I've held for like many years.
I've always thought that it should be fine to react in full to
a video as long as you're putting putting some effort in. Obviously
in this case some of them did not benefit into their reacts and
um I would don't necessarily be against them getting sued for
it. It depends. It depends where there's precedent set. I don't
want like react harder enshrined in the laws. There's a lot of
things to consider there. But generally my position is as long
as you are making a real effort to engage in a transformative
way with the piece of media you're consuming then yes and that
has always been my position. That's a very common position online
that I think uh even since like you know Ethan's first lawsuit
many people took. Um, so I don't think this is a motivated reasoning
thing. I've had I've had that position position for a real personally
be, right? Like I mean obviously I've got more of a buy in. Am
I likely to change that position when it would affect my bottom
line? Like probably not. I mean, maybe you could say that, but
the idea that I've just reasoned out this position from Supreme
doesn't care about motivated reason. That's just not true. That's
a position I held on before I had motivational.
I believe that. But I still think it's I still think it comes
at too great an intersection to um like the traffic that it diverts
away from. That's wrong. But also creator's original works. I
need 10 more dollars. And you know what? Like I I have your cake
and YouTube, but I think our well established we both understand
them at this point. Give subs. Donate. Donate. Donate. Donate.
Yeah. I just like I said, I just don't see how you um go back
to like what what is it? Are we talking about AI enforcement?
Like AI enforcement of copyright. This could be a thing where
there's an algorithm that says whether you react hard hard enough
and it takes down your video if you didn't. How awesome would
that be? First off, that's not unrealistic at all. Like that's
kind of what DMCA and doesn't sound like a nightmarish world.
One where people's works are protected and we have one where
it's like an algorithm deciding like every decision about which
video is taken down based on whether there was enough. Now you
sound like the scared old man who you sound like the scared boomer.
Any automated systems for things that are like subjective are
always going to leave something to be desired. I think content
we already have one of those. It's called DMCA and Content ID.
That's not an automated system for things that supposed to be
subjective. That's a system where you you file file a legal notice.
And it's an automated system that detects when you're using somebody
else's No, no, that's Content ID is a is a separate thing to
DMCA. Content ID is a YouTube system that detects content and
most people hate that. Yeah, that's true. But it the whole point
of content ID is that like the next mechanism is that it allows
you to identify people who are using your content so that you
can initiate a DMA if applicable. Right. I mean, not necessarily.
It's also for revenue sharing and Okay. Yeah, I think those are
good mechanisms. Yeah. Like if YouTube had a Okay, let's imagine
this, right? If YouTube implemented this is my perfect solution.
Just split the ad revenue. Just split the [__] I
just wish there was a license where you could say this is my
piece of content I'm putting out. If people want to add it to
their content, here's the split I want. And then people could
just The thing is, I don't think that's going to be achieved.
I don't think it's going to be achieved through a lawsuit like
this. I don't think that's going to But who it could be. I mean
again like that's the that's the ideal outcome that requires
like Congress to do something in my opinion. Yeah. Yeah. Or a
federal case and something like a federal case can draw that
sort of attention that Congress can do. And listen again the
first ad apocalypse came up with content ID and part of what
content ID does is rev sharing, right? Like this would just be
kind of a new iteration of uh of the type of solution. So okay
Supreme, can I bring you around to this position? This is a monopoly
issue but go ahead. I want to bring you around to this position.
I want to try and convince you of this. If I if I can convince
a anti-react guy of this at least, do you think this lawsuit
is in any way likely to achieve a good outcome for the ecosystem
or do you think it is just going to be bad in a different way?
Uh I don't I don't necessarily think that uh what we got out
of the ad apocalypse was bad in a different way. Um I think it
was an evolution and like a sort of what do you call it like
a triage. But this is different to the ad apocalypse that would
be more comparable to the Twitch uh campaign. This I'm talking
about specifically the copyright stuff, the copyright lawsuit
that Ethan's filing. Do you think this would actually produce
good outcomes in like a good position, a good system for copyright
on YouTube and on the internet or do you think it's just going
to be but I mean like maybe some people you don't like get screwed
over. Yeah, I think it will I think it'll be better or it'll
promote a better ecosystem that rewards people for original works.
Okay. Either either one of those two things. Yes. I mean, you're
just basically telling me government bad. Government can't do
anything. I'm not saying government bad. No, no, no. I'm No,
I'm not saying that at all. I mean, the government think it's
possible. No, no. The government could do something, right? Congress
could could come and pass a bill. Do I think YouTube on their
own devices? But no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'm saying through
the lawsuit that Ethan Klein is filing, lawsuits that Ethan Klein
is filing. Do you think they are likely, if they lead to anything,
to produce a good outcome, or do you think it will just still
be in a different way? Do I do I think that this lawsuit will
even be one
paving a road towards a better solution affect the YT VOD numbers
of viewers and watch time? No, I I I'm not I'm trying when I
say a a good outcome, not just funded a different way. I'm try
what I'm trying to get across is do you think it will act it
will fix the situation? Do you think it will set us on the right
track? There might be like some incremental change that you like
wrong with what I just said because there's I think there's a
difference between there being sort of like an incremental change
in an ecosystem that might be in a way that you find preferable
versus
making steps towards having a better system. Yeah. Like uh I
mean what's what's different between what you just said having
uh taking steps towards a better system and Yeah. Those are differences.
So a better system would be but sorry. No, between saying that
and me saying do I think this will even be one stone in the ground
towards paving the way for a better solution. That sounds like
exactly No. Yeah. I mean it can No, the thing you're saying I
feel like can mean either of things I said but I'm trying to
draw a distinction between two different things. I'm trying to
figure out which one you mean. So either do So it's here are
the two options giving you. Um, when you say step in the ground,
a a stone in the ground or whatever, do you think that will actually
lead towards a better system that like is top down where people
can better guarantee their copyright
um in general like everyone, not just uh the top level or do
you think this is likely to just sort of put some people off
of watching like Ethan's content or maybe similar content? Do
you think it's any Do you think the outcomes of this are likely
to be enshrined or systematized in any way? Yeah, I think I think
so. Yeah, I think this
a catalyst of of some size even if it's small. Yeah. Okay. Um
Yeah. I guess I just don't really believe that. I think the arguments
I think the arguments in the lawsuit a landmark case right
I don't think the lawsuits in the case the arguments in the lawsuit
a lot of them don't really support the idea that it would move
towards a better system. I feel like a lot of it is focused on
whether Denims knows enough about politics to talk about this
or not.
Oh, interesting. Um, I didn't get that when we went through the
dockets earlier. So there there's quite there's quite a bit in
there from what I saw about how um it goes through like different
talking points that uh Dennis was like engaging with or saying
and then it tries to site articles that disprove her talking
points and it talks about how she's uninformed and couldn't give
substantive commentary and critique. Um is this the lawsuit you're
talking about? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. We didn't finish reading it.
Yeah. We may not have gotten there yet, but Oh yeah. So that's
part of it. So arguments like that I think are incredibly concerning.
Uh especially if they get enshrined. I think that that would
even be potentially a worse situation especially for free speech.
I think that is concerning saying this person is not qualified
even to Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Dumb people should be allowed
to talk about politics too. Okay. I understand why we had such
a disconnect. I literally just wasn't familiar with that part
of the docu. Yeah, certainly. I agree. Maybe we should Are we
still debating or should we move through the content? Are are
we talking Hold on. Are we talking about like the start of the
document where they're like, "Oh, Denim's commentary is like
dumb and doesn't actually make a good point and it's I think
it's spoken about in multiple places. I watch Lone the Box through
most there's like four there's four different points they make
about how bad Denim's commentary is and then they address the
fact that there's 70 minutes of it and I have multiple morons
in my chat who are arguing that Denims didn't say anything. She
just rebroadcast this." No, they literally missed out more than
70 minutes of content that she commented. Yeah. They say that
commentary doesn't count because she's not informed enough and
sounds like a basically. Yeah, I think that's really dangerous.
But um I also don't think I have some faith in like in Los Angeles
courts and well I guess federal court in this case to like look
at that and be like that has nothing to do with sure if you think
okay and yeah you might have faith in the courts but you you
would say that this reflects very poorly on Ethan as the paragon
of fair use and free speech that he is trying to use arguments.
I no that it doesn't matter. This is representation. Someone
representing him wrote that. So
yeah. And I have no idea how like Yeah. I don't know. It might
have like I have no idea how much of this like what came out
of that docket is is like Ethan meeting with his lawyer and it
basically being like a therapy session where Ethan is just like
just spouting out all his grievances and then the lawyer
taking my content and Yeah. Yeah. Okay. But that's what happens
when you let pettiness take over
like your principles, right? You end up making really poor judgments
and you start attacking things that probably don't align with
your original goals. But that's for Yeah. Yeah. I don't know.
Again, listen, if it's a if it's a woman who's going after a
drunk driver who hit her son or something like that and she's
like crying, she's like, "Fuck this guy. Throw the book at him."
And she's like, you know, throwing anything.
Yeah. But everybody else Yes. to make sure that the correct situ
that the correct outcome occurs regardless of what the victim
is emotionally demanding.
Exactly. So don't put a cape on this. Um yeah, he's not principled
anymore. I've been like for two years everyone has just been
like, "Ethan's really hurt, guys. You don't understand. He has
to send out a bunch of legal threats every other week." Hold
on. You guys don't think I I like endorse literally everything
Ethan No, but I No, but but when you bring it up, it's like people
hearing that. No, I I am going against the grain of people saying
like, oh, I think it's silly to make like center your entire
commentary around this over he's just trying to with these people
because I I truly think that it's like a good lawsuit that I've
been hoping for for a long time this sort of thing happening
and yeah, I recognize that certainly it's uh coming as a consequence
of I'm not even sure. I would say I would say I can see how you
would think it could be have a good outcome, but I don't think
if you read it the nature of the lawsuit I agree
Yeah. Well, I mean would do you agree with I mean I assume you
don't agree with writing off the commentary because it's uninformed.
Of course not. No, that sounds that sounds really dangerous.
But I just feel like when you Yeah. When I feel like you wouldn't
I some of the lawsuit you would have major issues with. I feel
like well if he was going through the lawsuit with us on stream
we haven't even finished the introduction. So, um, supporting
the lawsuit is probably preemptive right now and maybe you won't
after you get to read the goal as stated by Ethan of the lawsuit
is agreed with the basic outline as as understood is agreed with.
There might be details I think are like silver or dangerous or
something. Yes. But yeah, no, I mean like I don't think you need
to go through the entire docket to the intro statement is something
I agree with in the nature of the lawsuit and and like the details
that he's putting in as far as this is how I know these people
are guilty of this thing that I say you know in the intro statement
of the lawsuit. Like I agree. Certainly a lot of the other like
I don't know you guys can see in well I guess you can't see in
the chat like hours ago I was like that seems like a weird thing
for him to include and I can't remember what it was but yeah
certainly there's a lot of that like this this hardly seems relevant.
There's that whole thing about Hassan being the new uh what is
it? M whatever. Okay. Oh yeah that's that's a
okay Ethan. Okay Ethan. Yeah we get it man. Everyone's like the
nasty the antise-semitism is like why why is that the MY and
Hitler and the MY and Himmler. Yeah. What are you doing? Why
insane? Okay, I think I pulled Ryland. Guys, if you want to if
you want to disagree waiting room in the in the Discord, okay,
I've seen a whole bunch of you people in the chat who are just
like, "Oh my god, Ethan's the best. I totally agree with everybody
who agrees with Ethan." I would love for you to join the VC and
come argue uh argue your position. I know you won't. I know none
of these people will. I know they're all I was to come on my
stream earlier. It was awful. It's like no, no one wants to come
on and just actually talk about this. The Razle Smasher guy.
The Razzle Smasher guy was psyched earlier and now he stopped
talking. Is he still there? Oh, we got some died in the wall.
Nicholas Dioro fans in here pronto. I don't have any of the people
around anymore. She is here with us in spirit if nothing else.
Where are I?
Supreme real quick. Supreme, if you don't mind. Uh, so Ethan,
you agree, has leapfrogged the existing DMCA system, right? 99%
of like YouTube videos
that streamer.
Okay. I just want to point out that I I literally asked Riyle,
"Are you coming in to disagree with us or are you like just coming
to yell at Supreme?" And he said, "I disagree." Nice one. I said
I disagree with Supreme. That's That's fine. Oh, can you DMCA
on Is there like a button to do that on Twitch? Like DMCA?
You can you can you can literally email anything if they don't
react to DMCAs via some contact form they have that that company
will get if you if you take them to they have to comply with
their uh with the protections right I see. Yeah. So sorry you
you just said that if you DMCA somebody and it got taken down
and then you also try to copyright claim them is that then you
get in court. Is that what you're saying? Or you have to pay
a penalty. But but what you're asking, sorry, what you're asking
me, Ry, is would you say that he uh intentionally chose not to
DMCA so that he could escalate to federal court? Correct. Uh
yeah, I think that's probably what he did. Gotcha. And so that's
probably bad. We would agree. And also, no, not necessarily.
No, I think it's his right to take him to court. And I don't
think that he should have the expectation that he should align
with all the schedules of any streamer that he may predict is
going to steal his content and be there to strike it live or
like hire people to to watch them and strike it live. No, I don't
think that he has that obligation. I think like kind of lied
in his video. I'm not going to lie. When he's talking about like
having a really high standard for, you know, who he's going to
strike and he talks about how, you know, I wanted to make sure
it was like completely clean. I want it to be an irresistible
piece of prepared content that they just couldn't wait to watch.
But, I mean, he registered the Doomsday Countdown stream as well
and is suing Denims for watching the Doomsday Countdown stream.
Sorry. Sorry. What's the uh am I being proposed? So, he's he's
suing Denims for watching one of his streams, something Denims
had been doing for over a year and something he'd been doing
back to Dems for over a year. Yeah. And uh and the the other
thing is obviously in the video he claims it was going to be
specifically he was fighting on a piece of prepared content.
He he specified prepared because as in versus streamed uh versus
live because obviously people would think it was ridiculous if
you were were suing people for reacting to the H3 podcast. Yeah.
And who would be a hypocrite? Exactly like Ethan. But that's
not the case because he registered that stream with with the
Library of Congress and suing Denims for watching that stream
as well. It's in the um claim for relief. So uh shoot. Yeah,
that seems pretty hypocritical. That that certainly doesn't look
good on his part cuz I would Yeah, I was I was going to say,
well then Denims could just sue him for going over any of her
streams, but she did not register them with the Library of Congress
beforehand in order to Yeah, that's obviously try and get the
statue or it's not even beforehand. You have to do it within
3 months and you did it on like the 21st of uh March or something
which 2 months after the first uh airing. Um wait, whoa, wait
a minute. So he cop he's he registered it months after. Two months
after the airing. Yeah, she watched it live. And when did she
watch it? She watched it live. Well, then how could she possibly
be? Well, what I'm saying is you have three months to give you
three months to if you register within three months of producing
it. Yes, they'll count it as you're basically registering a day
of
Yeah, that that just seems like uh that seems hypocritical on
his part for sure. And just to be clear, um now that Queman's
here, I can point out I told Queman about this like two months
ago. Like two months ago, we talked about this exact strategy
and we both agreed that it would be insane for Ethan to sue his
critics now. Like we we thought, okay, he moved on. He's not
going to do it. He There's no way he would think about it. And
he did. He's done it. Okay, let me ask you let me ask you guys
this. What is the timeline between him uh copyright or registering
the stuff with Library of Congress and Denim's
threatening to sue him? Um he she threatened to sue him after
he'd registered it. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, that's that looks bad on
his part then. Unless I don't know. Maybe you can. It's two months
after the original airing. And here's the thing. Here's what
I think. Denim.
Well, no, it's not just a trap. I think this is like super because
basically what's happened is Denim's watched like the Doomsake
countdown stream or like an hour of it or something without a
lot of commentary cuz it's like just Ethan rambling and like
waiting until the video drops basically. And then obviously when
the video comes out, she actually does like a significant portion
of commentary and actually reacts to that. So I think personally
what happened is Ethan thought, okay, it's not quite slam dunk
on the video, so I need to register the stream as well. Yeah.
Yeah, that seems Yeah. I don't know. That seems dishonest.
Yeah. And he doesn't point that out in the video. And you know,
obviously it's hypocritical. It's just like Yeah. It's like not
a good faith attempt to protect your intellectual property is
like insanely malicious.
It is about the person with guys. Listen, whatever your if you
tell your lawyer a bunch of and he adds a bunch of you know what
I mean? Like if he starts throwing stuff at the wall, I don't
think that necessarily means you're not sincere. This isn't just
throwing stuff at the wall. He knows what's in that lawsuit.
He knows that he's suing for that. He knows that he registered
with the Library of Congress 2 months after Den had already reacted
to it. He's fully aware of all this and he's behaving this way
knowingly. But let me let me rephrase. I don't think winning
by hook or by crook means you aren't winning uh with any other
sort of purpose or that there's like you know that that necessarily
but if no no no no no no Ethan's claim is that he is doing this
to protect individual you know content prepared content from
the react slop evil [__] okay that's his claim part
of his claim his other part of his claim is that he's gener making
generational wealth for his lawyers can I can I get you So, pause
for Do you think that was a serious claim or No, of course not.
That sounded like a joke to start the stream with. Or maybe pause
for one moment. Uh, Jay, please pull up Aristocracy TV's tweet.
Someone explain. I'm trying to get Aris to come on the stream.
She was watching earlier. [__] Oh,
people. Just somebody explain it. Maybe she'll still come and
explain to us. I'll read it. Yeah, I'll read it. I'll read it.
XQC admits he is not sufficiently reacting to Ethan Klein's content,
Duke, and is instead just watching. Ethan Klein says he respects
and acknowledges him for not reacting sufficiently to his content.
Nuke, he is now suing Three Moon for not sufficiently reacting
to his content. And then it's the ox.
1 minute 36. Yes. Yes. This is this is forces analogy, but yes,
it's it's also true. People said to react this, react that. We
don't hate react. It's lazy. I I I actually invented watching.
I invented watching. People think reacting on stream. No, watching.
I'm not reacting to this. I'm watching this. What about it?
To analyze. Well, anyway, my my criticism isn't that he's like
watching, it's that he's watching terrorist propaganda. But it's
a little different, but I I hear your point. And I and listen,
I respect it, man. I acknowledge you. We hear you. I acknowledge.
I respect it. I just respect the way you watch this instead of
commentating XQC. I just respect that. Okay. I respect you. I
respect I respect. You understand? hard for me to like interpret
that perfectly literally. I I understand. I Here's the interpretation.
He hates XQC. He's not picking fights on multiple fronts right
now. What if What if he started clapping his hand and goes, "Man,
this you're the legend, man." Would I be like, "Oh my look, he
called him the legend. He called him." That's not what That isn't
what James said, is it? I'm saying that he doesn't like him.
He's just not going to pick a fight with XQC right now. That
he he doesn't like XQC. He doesn't like that he's doing that.
He's just not going to pick a fight on multiple fronts. That's
what he's professional. Right. That's how you're paraphrasing.
But what you actually did was we watched the collido the video
and then you [__] uh you repeated what he said verbatim
as if I should interpret it literally.
I think it's embarrassing that he will not stand on his principles.
Show the street. Let's let's see what Aris said about it. I want
to hear what
aristocracy said, "People trying to defend this is honestly hilarious.
Once upon a time, it was legal to steal from a successful Jew.
But Ethan lives in 2025 America.
It's all about anti-semitism. Really, it's all about people think
it's okay to just steal from everyone just thinks it's fine to
just go around stealing from all the time.
It was illegal to steal from a successful Jew who who
um it would just be stolen from Jews. Jerry, what successful
Jew was stolen from in America? Aristocracy survived the Toronto
pograms. Okay, you put some respect on Aristocracy's name. I
want to I want to send this tweet to Abba Atlas. Can we get Abba
Atlas to comment on how much the have been stolen from legally
in America? Can I get Aba Atlas's opinion on this stat? Hello?
Does anybody have contact with ABBA? I need ABBA's opinion right
now. She's only allowed to cry. So I up. She was watching earlier.
She came in my Twitch chat earlier and was like, "Hey, I'm watching
criticism and like maybe I'll argue with some people on this
later." and I'll message her later on. I I I don't This is a
Listen, this is a ridiculous aristocracy. She's done debate panels
before. She's not like brand new to Blood Sports or anything.
So, Ethan is not unique and that people like people reacting
to Ethan's content. This is not unique to Ethan or James, right?
Like this is this is just a ridiculous tweet. Well, also wait,
you're telling me aristocracy is making a hysterical tweet about
about people with attitudes towards there's no freaking way.
I ain't getting between you guys. This is a JJ thing. Kimman,
you can if you're if you're speaking anything unironically. This
is like the most obvious like um pushing the
moment in his She just she just doesn't hate herself like you
do, right? She could see another get like skulls sent to him
and she understand
behind that where you aristocracy loves queen is she like the
only person defending Ethan supreme you're out of date on the
on the law here okay I'm so arrogant in my duty
nothing supremacist than aristocracy is aristocracy aristocracy
is just not supremacist aristocracy yeah aristocracy thinks are
weak and just be it can just be you know aristocracy thinks like
these weak people that need protection all the time. We've been
sitting here like, you know what? The Holocaust made us strong
and we've been too long. It's been too long since the last pogram.
We need another one to to strengthen us again. That's what he's
saying. Okay. I like it. I like it. Crazy. Your Pokemon don't
level up if you don't send him into battle. Is that so true?
And we're Charmeleons trying to become dinos. Did she have Did
she help him with the video? No. The victims of bad support group
the videos. Yeah, they have their victims of bad empanada support
group where they were talking about what the [__]
is this comment underneath.
Brianna Woo just got out of her latest surgery. Okay, she's ready.
She's the She's officially the um what that is. She's the strongest
golem Israel has ever created. Okay, there is literally nothing
human left. She's one of those iron golems in Minecraft. That's
what is blanky like that. I don't know what any of those words
mean.
Oh god. And I don't want to know. You got the shoulders. Gets
goofy sometimes. I don't know. This stream gets pretty goofy.
She got She got the three block shoulders. Nope. None of us can
say anything past that. What's next? I don't know. I don't know
what's next. I think we were supposed to read more of this lawsuit.
Guys, support the Patreon. We're going to need it soon. Bank
accounts for much longer. People's physical appearance unless
they're comically fat. Okay. Sure. That was a little deeper than
just a physical appearance joke. Okay. Uh son is bad. Little
deeper than that. That's what I'm saying. True. He went straight
to the bones. Um, do we have anybody join a waiter right now?
Do you remember? No, hold on, hold on, hold on. Do you remember
when this [__] was like, I don't do drama? I'm like,
actually, I care about like legislation. I'm I'm doing politics.
Is her body ready for What is she doing in here in this thread?
Sh. We just watched Ted Cruz explain that with absolutely no
other motivation, he just loves Israel. He was ready to be like,
I'm I'm I want to be a senator because I'm going to be Israel's
strongest defender in the Senate. Okay. How is def defending
Israel is a political defendator. This
defendator. It's too late for us. Defender. Senator. Defender.
Defender. Okay. Defenestrator.
Defenestrator. He would push somebody out of a window. Listen,
I love hanging out with you guys. You guys are fun. It's just
so great. Ethan Quan literally got sued for live reacting to
pay-per-view content and lost and now this like cried about it
and now it's Did he lose that? I think people before he lost
all of it, dude. He's settled. He just settled before starting
these. He had to go on stream and gravel and say that Ryan Kavanaaugh
is a great guy and all this stupid. Ryan Kavanagh was the was
a separate thing. I think he tried to accuse Ryan Kavanaaugh
of being part of that first lawsuit. Yeah, but that's because
he No, no, no. But he wasn't. He just had stake in it. So, what
happened with Ryan Kavanaaugh is um I believe he owned or had
staken Triller it which ran the pay-per-view of some fight that
Ethan reacted to and then sued for copyright infringement and
he was crying about that and then he started going on about how
Ryan Kavanaaugh ran a Ponzi scheme which was a disproven allegation
that the article retract well I don't anyway the article retracted
it but Ethan kept going on about how he was running a Ponzi scheme
running a Ponzi game like you double down a million times and
he just gradually settled a lost area of the lawsuit along the
way and just finally settled the last one for defamation. Had
to walk it all back and say he's a great guy basically. Yikes.
That was the anti-Slap thing that they had you bring up earlier.
J. Yes, it was. It was a Yahoo link. Do I still have it open?
I actually don't. But it because it was a Yahoo link, I might
only have so many Yahoo Yeah, I do only have so many Yahoo articles.
So there it is. Yeah. Funny things about that. Ethan Klein was
going around saying that basically um
a lot of people thought that he won. He was saying Yeah. No,
they're totally wrong. He was saying that Ryan Kavanaaugh um
was a Karen for complaining about his community sending Ryan
Kavanaaugh death threats. He was saying he was a Karen for a
Karen for a Karen for reporting them to Reddit. Uh he was saying
that that he was crying about their Reddit being included in
the lawsuit. He was crying about uh the fact that they attributed
their Reddit's actions to Ethan uh when I don't have any control
over my Reddit. I don't have control over who posts there. Uh
he was actually making these arguments. You know, all this insane
that is totally betrayed now. It's so pathetic. I seriously,
dude, this guy's the most disgusting person alive right now.
It's actually So basically, if the skulls came from Ryan Kavanaaugh,
then Ethan has no right to complain then, right? Can you get
Ryan Kavanaaugh to come out and take responsibility for those?
I'm looking for him. Jeez.
Oh, whoops. Okay, hold on. We haven't watched this yet. Ethan
Klein lost the defamation case against Ryan Kavanagh and is now
being made to gravel as part of the settlement. Ethan Klein gets
humiliated and humbled. Ryan Kavanagh, you dumb loser. Dumbass
loser. Drunk
drunk ass. It's crazy how big Ethan was.
you. This isn't even status. Accusing someone of being like an
alcoholic and saying they're like a disgusting person who runs
a Ponzi scheme. It's almost like similar to saying that like
they maybe like abuse their employees or that uh they have covering
their house. It's almost exists
being nicer to those Indians. We're really Is there a you don't
hate? Jesus.
I love them.